das ist kion day zum in der reportage
zum thema anorexie coaches vielen dank
für eure ganzen kommentare von euch die
frage und auch für kritik wofür es bald
kommt er gar nicht so genau es war die
für euch handvoll ihre erfahrungen mit
der magersucht berichtet alexandra
schreibt ich hatte magersucht aber wegen
dieser gruppen hatte ich probleme
bekommen wenn man unbedingt abnehmen
möchte dann macht man leider sehr vieles
dafür und leider gibt es personen die
das ausnützen deswegen immer aufpassen
und franziska schreibt ich bin
schockiert was alles passiert ich leide
selber unter magersucht seit 42 jahren
ich bin ohnmächtig wenn ich das sehe und
ich finde keine worte
danke vielmals dass ihre gesichter mit
als eltern ist nämlich deutlich
krankheit auf keinen fall allein mit dem
brg erkranken rund 3,5 prozent vor der
schweizer bevölkerung in ihrem leben an
einer essstörung bitte magersucht sind
das bitte frau rund 12 prozent bei der
man nicht 0,2 prozent hast du oder
reporting unfall hilfe brauchen findet
der ohne die video beschrieb egal
aufsteller in einer mega gefreut wie
positiv reagiert hat mit herzlichen dank
an jeanette dass sie sich hier so offen
zeigt und auskunft gibt ich denke das
wird für viele betroffene sie hilft
vielleicht sein und die geräte decke ist
so schön und der jonas fritschi nicht
wirklich eine frau mit viel ausstrahlung
wünsche dir dass du diese essstörung
komplett hinter dir lassen kannst in den
kommentaren mike freut auch willig sonne
zahl wird als sie selbst reflektiert die
person kennengelernt haben und jetzt
mega stark für ihre dass ich so offen
über ihre krankheit gerettet und darüber
ihre erfahrung mit einer coaches sie ist
jetzt sieht es vortag wieder die heime
und wie es ihr jetzt gott erfahren
sie hat sofort das video geschickt
dann greifen wir für die cholera und
feedbacks und unserem video es hat mich
meine frau das las und das ist ja auch
ruhig und das spannung von der hand ich
bin immer dankbar dafür dass sich der
wert auf 100 teil von mir und familie
dafür 40
ist sehr speziell mit dem video zu sehen
aber ich bin stolz für mich dass ich das
hat er für machen und mich auch eine
öffnung und viel licht und außerdem auch
eine harfe oder kriegt augen öffnen
ja ich bin jetzt zwei wochen die
heimatstädte vor der klinik und ich muss
sagen der anfang ich lache holtwick sie
aber jetzt mit dem wieder gas und als
ich natürlich immer noch jeden tag eine
herausforderung
es gibt da gar nix besseres getan hat
eine ganz schlechte erfahrung mit dem
asse aber ich bin motiviert ich glaube
ich will das schaffen und ich gebe nicht
auf
mini message nach wieso bin ich bevor
ich war in der reportage gründe ich bin
auch ich reise sexual chips oder coaches
[Musik]
distanzierte sich von dem reddot mit
abrupten euch ab immer grauer es ist
eine gut für euch erstellt euch und das
ist für euch so ein paar lara gut
ist eine reise uhr sa und so hilft das
ist einzige was ich euch
das herz gemacht und
dann halt doch es war für euch glaubt
hat mehr als es regnete coaches und
unternehmer zum beispiel zu der polizei
könnten sie auch zeigen der flug etwas
gibt verstehe ich das richtig essen das
schweizer radio und fernsehen ihr habt
die fälle nicht der polizei
weitergeleitet what the [ __ ] und janina
schreibt was macht da das erste das
könnt ihr das einfach so hinnehmen
reichensteuer maker eure unmut und wie
hat sich auf das thema macht eure
aufgabe als journalistisches arbeit
probleme aufzeigen und missstand oft
stecken darum ist es wichtig dass wir
vor der strafverfolgungsbehörde
unabhängig liefert damit zur geschichte
überhaupt möglich sind also damit sich
betroffene überhaupt getraut mit
äußerster im besten fall und
publikationen natürlich dazu führen dass
betroffene anzeige erstattet das ist
aber ihre einseitig und ich als
reporterin kann niemandem vorschreiben
was sie so machen wir es doch ist war
kommentar und spekulationen auch geld zu
der identität von den coaches also wer
sich hinter der jets versteckt logical
imperiums liebt was die motivation mädel
ist weiß ich nicht auf alle fälle krank
ich verstehe eure encaustic coaches
welle als psychopathen oder aus rang ab
zu stampfen aber ganz so einfach ist es
nützt mir ist wichtig dass man das thema
differenziert muss der recherche und das
gespräch mit experten weisen dass hinter
jedem kothe andere motivation verstecke
und dass sie nicht unbedingt krank sind
man kann sich ja destruktiv halte ohne
psychisch kranke und micha psychisch
krank sie ohne quartal stelle für sie
mit menschen und das ist der fall bei
der allermeisten psychisch kranke
menschen darum finde ich wichtig dass
man die coaches in die tägliche talks
meist dann hat es doch einige kommentare
wo sich für die recht wie viel lag im
zusammenhang mit einer coaches
interessiert ohne dass quartals liebt
was mich interessiert hätte ob es
politische das leben gibt dieses
schreckliche vorgehensweisen der coaches
zu gelangen weißt du da wie die
politische lage aussieht und maddalena
schrieb ich finde es ganz krass dass
dieses gezielte anbahnen von erwachsenen
mit minderjährigen im internet in der
schweiz nicht strafbar ist da muss
rechtlich unbedingt etwas geschehen
genau zahl bekommen ist bis heute die
schweiz kann einige strafbestand
einzelne handlungen bestraft werden wie
zum beispiel sexuelle belästigung oder
nötigung
weiß ich das ist aber schwierig ist dass
das überhaupt das licht und die
betroffene schämen sich oft für den
kontakt mit einer coaches und vertraut
sich nehmen weil sie angst hat vor der
stigmatisierung
momentan tut sich kaum gewehrt aber
tatsächlich als bitterböse initiative
greift oder im parlament wo verlangt das
schweizerische strafgesetzbuch so
anpasst wird das saalvolumen als
offizialdelikt unter strafe gestellt
wird frist für die initiative laufen ob
ich zu den winter 22 24 wird euch unter
mich so beschäftigt mit mexiko zu
unternehmen
telefoniere ich hätte ihn gerade mit dem
nina hobby sie schafft beim bundesamt
für sozialversicherungen und die steht
projektleiterin jugend und medien und wo
er wird die größe nicht maßnahmen auf
dem gebiet
was müssen sie beim bundesamt für
sozialversicherung über das phänomen von
deiner anorexie coaches dass wir darüber
wissen das phänomen ist im moment zum
glück extrem verbreitet ist april im
einzelfall natürlich sehr gravierend die
folgen kann haut trug zu dieser
wichtigsten wir möchten die von ihrer
verantwortung auf das thema aufmerksam
machen
die hochwirksamen der ganze
block text dazu veröffentlichte das
angesprochen wird durch diese website
physisches ahnung sagte zwischen was für
die informationen und wieviel dem sind
tyler und wieviel focus lecker beruf
seines thema will
immer gefahr dass sie informationen
im großen kontext noch dieses thema ich
aber gleichzeitig spiele direkt die
coaches ein solches album thematik in
seiner gründung ist momentan dass wir
noch kein eigener strafbestand findet
sie dass draxler die gesetzeslage so wie
sie jetzt ist es genug zum die
schweizer grundlage grundlegend
straftat
ob sie online oder offline begangen wird
die schweizer berge
tatsächlich spezifische online
straftatbestand in den allermeisten
fällen genügt das ist das offline das
gilt auch und als grundlage also
definitiv möglichkeit
dass unter ihnen sind kaputt machen
indem sie ins gesetz das problem ist
einfach dass sie also wir kommen gut an
unternehmen und so weiter und
social networks passiert ist das extrem
schwierig
tatsächlich noch ein deal oder überhaupt